in our serious school matters we take
you to once videos finding success with
a unique lesson plan Massachusetts is
ranked first in the nation in K through
12 education and Worcester Technical
School is part of the reason why the
Vocational Technical High School boasts
a graduation rate of more than 99
percent that compares to an eighty four
percent rate nationwide and with classes
on everything from hospitality to
carpentry graduates are not just ready
for college but also the workforce the
four hundred thousand square-foot
Worcester tech building is impressive
but what's going on inside is what's
truly special it's a public school with
a little more than 1,400 students and
along with typical high school classes
22 vocational and technical areas of
study are consolidated into a single
campus including some you won't find
anywhere else
like the Tufts at Tech veterinary clinic
it's a real life working veterinary
clinic that combines students like
Daniel with doctors from Tufts like
Kayla what is the most important aspect
of this partnership for you going up I
was always fascinated with animals so
getting an experience with them here in
a high school was the biggest motivation
to me my big dream overall is to open up
my own clinic nothing is sugar-coated in
this environment dr. Greg Wolfe --is who
runs the clinic says the hands-on
experience for the students is
unparalleled our high school students
are getting trained in not only being
veterinary care future professionals but
additionally they're learning how to be
good and active citizens by providing
veterinary services to their neighbors
Worcester Tech student body is diverse
more than half our girls who get their
hands dirty under cars and trained to be
plumbers
and welders the school has a credit
union where students work as tellers
there's cosmetology with manicures and
facials in culinary arts students learn
to prepare food and bake pastries and
they cater as many as 75 events each
year and 86 percent of Worcester tech
graduates go on to college the biotech
department uses college-level equipment
that allows students to extract and
examine their own DNA that same
technology helps them solve lock crimes
Sophia here is a junior and you've been
part of this program now for a few years
what do you enjoy most about it I think
how fascinating the human brain is and
this is a path you want to pursue and
throughout college yes very much
I really want to be a pediatrician and
specifically develop a program directed
at protecting the child's brain
Worcester Tech is one example of why
Massachusetts is first in education in
the u.s. what are you doing to maintain
that number one status when we've
invested over five hundred million
dollars in new funding at the state
level we spoke with governor Charlie
Baker in the school's automotive shop he
says vote X schools are an important
part of what makes Massachusetts number
one their ability to apply exactly what
they have learned in the classroom in a
very real-world way really brought sort
of a sense of purpose and made a huge
difference in the training that they're
getting here in this department we'll do
what in the future world that they're in
there are a lot of kids doing coop out
of our voc tech schools where they're
making over $20 an hour in professions
where that skill capability can
translate into 70 80 90 100 120 thousand
dollars a year if you stick with it that
real-world experience pays off for the
community as well students built a new
bridge more than 50 feet long in a
nearby historical park and in advanced
engineering they're creating a monument
to Worcester area veterans of World War
one and they're not above putting their
skills to use for a vanity project
so Randy wow this looks familiar yes it
is for us here yes it is for you guys I
was so impressed by these students by
the teachers the collaboration with
universities nearby like the veterinary
clinic that was the best burger I ate
and they need the local community and
they host many events there the rich
they don't beiong yes the bridge they
really give back to the community and
they have lifelong lessons they can take
with them for those that do choose to go
to college after that many of them just
go and have great jobs because of the
skills they learn from the school yeah
all I made in my home at class was an
apron and that wasn't even very good and
you we know you don't use that for
excellent Robert Robert didn't get long
she's right she's right I can't even act
like yes joy you're wrong no she's
absolutely right but I love the level of
this school and the people there it's a
positive story and that's what we
inspired about the future generation of
kids now if they go to schools like
these I'm all for more vocational stuff
yeah